Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is the
last hurray for the franchise so you'll
be forgiven for having to wipe away a
tear or two here's what you may not have
caught if you were too deep in your
feelings spoilers ahead
the first MCU Film Iron Man opened with
an animated intro in which the pages of
a comic book Flipped eventually
revealing the Marvel Studios logo as
more films got added to the franchise
those intros began to feature more
Marvel characters and eventually script
Pages live action scenes from the movies
and the theme music that fans know and
love every once in a while Marvel
Studios gets creative with its opening
title sequence when they do it's usually
to mark an occasion for example the
werewolf By Night Disney plus special
included a Marvel Studio signature that
was a throwback to classic monster
movies while the Black Panther wakanda
forever opening was a tribute to the
late Chadwick Boseman Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 is both the final
installment in one of the mcu's most
popular mini franchises and James Gunn's
last collaboration with Marvel so this
time the Marvel Studios introduction is
entirely Guardians of the Galaxy themed
with images and quotes from the previous
installments volumes 1 and 2 did not
have unique intros but the Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special was seated by
a slightly altered intro set to
Christmas music in which various Marvel
incarnations of Santa are shown snow is
falling and string lights Adorn the
Marvel Studios font
the Guardians of the Galaxy first
appeared in Marvel Comics in 1969 though
that version barely resembles the MCU
team the source material from the films
mainly comes from story lines that begin
in 2008 when Star-Lord forms a group
with Rocket Raccoon Groot Gamora Drax
phylavel and Adam Warlock the first two
Guardians of the Galaxy films may have
borrowed characters and plot points from
the comics but they gave Star-Lord and
his associates unique outfits that were
meant to relay information about their
personalities the mcu's Peter Quill was
designed to look like a cross between a
cowboy and a rock star with the Swagger
of both but for the final film in the
trilogy the team is finally in their
Comics accurate suits the leathery red
and blue uniforms with the metallic
emblem on the chest very closely adhere
to the art of the 2008 Guardian series
the costumes also serve a practical
purpose Dave Batista has expressed
discomfort about playing the physically
impressive and often shirtless drags
into his 50s he's suited up to match his
Squad and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
which allowed Batista to avoid hours
worth of painstaking body makeup and to
relax a little about the state of his
physique similarly Drax wears a vest and
an ugly Christmas sweater in the
Guardians holiday special which was
filmed at the same time
music is deeply symbolic in the
Guardians of the Galaxy movies not only
are needle drops specifically chosen to
add meaning to moments the very idea of
music as a gift is Central to the
trilogy Quill's mom makes him his
awesome mixes volume 1 and 2 in the
first film which he plays on his Walkman
until ego destroys it near the end of
the second movie as that movie draws to
a close craglin gives quill one last
present from who became his father
figure yondu it's a Zune Microsoft's
version of the iPod which can hold more
and more modern music whatever Peter is
listening to on his own is what the
audience hears as well it's loaded up
with tracks that span from Bruce
Springsteen's 1978 hit Badlands to
Florence and The Machine's 2008 track
dog days are over whether Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 producers knew it or
not the Beastie Boys No Sleep chill
Brooklyn appears in both of Chris
Pratt's films currently in theaters this
one and the Super Mario Brothers movie
in the mid-credit Stinger rocket
mentions that his favorite song is come
and get your love which is the tune we
hear when we first meet quill rocking
out to his Walkman in the first
Guardians movie music and this Zune in
particular are so important to Star-Lord
that he very nearly dies trying to save
it in the vacuum of space in volume 3.
Star-Lord loves to dance he idolizes
Kevin Bacon in Footloose and uses the
power of dance to defeat Ronan in
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 1. when the
Guardians first assemble quill is the
only member who feels comfortable moving
and grooving baby Groot eventually gives
into the Rhythm but everyone else is
reluctant in the second guardian's film
Drax tells Star-Lord that he fell for
his late wife because she was the only
woman not dancing at a gathering
wouldn't even
wouldn't move enough
of a must one might assume she was dead
Drax Al dissuades quill from pursuing
Gamora because he says there are two
types of people those who dance and
those who don't and Gamora is not a
dancer but quill teaches Gamora to dance
on ego's planet and soon they confess
their love for each other and Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 Drax again insists
only idiots dance until the very end of
the third film Peter's friends consider
dancing silliness while not dancing is a
form of self-seriousness but after the
Guardians rescue the captives from the
high evolutionaries ship and return to
Nowhere music plays and everyone
including Drax and nebula starts to
Boogie this touching moment symbolizes
not only that the Guardians are all true
friends but that there's room for
frivolity even when the Galaxy's at
stake
as a test subject of the high
evolutionary rocket raccoons designation
89p13 is very prominent in Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 3. some Savvy fans might
remember that code appears elsewhere in
rocket story in volume 1 when he Groot
quill and Gamora are arrested after
their three-way melee on xandar the Nova
core identify him during the prison
lineup sequence with the same
alphanumeric code that graphic also
includes his rap sheet and his
associates Groot and Lila we finally get
to meet Lila otter who is his love
interest in the comics in volume 3. she
changes her name from her code
89q12 I would like my name to be
Lila rocket and Lila's subject codes
indicate that they're part of batch 89
have experimented upon animals that
group also includes thiefs who goes by
walrus in the comics and floor who's
probably a riff on Black Jack O'Hare
sadly batch 89 was the last imperfect
enough to be kept out of the high
evolutionaries supposedly utopian
counter-earth after a juvenile Rocket's
unintentional troubleshooting resulted
in batch 90's success the PE could be an
abbreviation for the raccoon's
scientific name proscian lotor and the
13 could merely mean that he's the 13th
animal in the test group though we
wouldn't put it past James Gunn to have
hidden another secret message in there
a collection of devoted fans Easter egg
hunters and code Breakers have been
working on solving a big Riddle That
James Gunn himself has been teasing for
years the writer director has seemingly
confirmed that some sleuths have gotten
close that theory has to do with Peter
Quill's mother Meredith possibly having
a larger role to play in The mcu's Wider
Story the evidence for it is a mural on
Morag and Peter uttering the word
eternity when ego shows him a vision of
his true purpose online investigators
have also been busy translating the
coordinates that appear under the names
of planets and other locations in the
Guardians of the Galaxy movies so far
those partially cracked codes gave away
spoilers for the second and third films
such as Meredith's cancer at the hand of
her former lover ego and the fact that
Herbert Wyndham the high evolutionary
would be doing experiments in a
biomedical Clinic Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 takes audiences to two new
locations the orgascope and counter
Earth sure enough there are new sets of
coordinates underneath the names of
these celestial bodies it doesn't
necessarily follow that they'd function
as spoiler since volume 3 is the last in
this Trilogy and gun won't be involved
in more MCU movies the more likely
scenario is that they'll provide the
enterprising fans who finally decipher
them with a missing piece of information
that either completes the infamous
Easter egg or adds context to whatever
it turns out to be
there are several actors pulling MCU
double duty and Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 3. Lila otter is voiced by Linda
Cardellini who played Clint Barton's
wife Laura Barton in three MCU films and
the Hawkeye TV series The High
evolutionaries War pig is voiced by Judy
Greer who also plays Scott Lang's
ex-wife Maggie in the first two Ant-Man
movies Nathan Fillion guns longtime
collaborator and friend was the voice of
monstrous inmate in volume 1 and he has
a larger part in volume 3 as Master
karja the Sentry Foreman on the
orgoscope Michaela Hoover was Nova
Prime's assistant in volume 1 and voices
the rabbit floor this time around Tara
Strong who provides the voice of
Mainframe does the same for Miss minutes
in Loki Gunn also dipped into the DC
casting well for volume 3. Daniela
melchior who starred as rat Catcher in
The Suicide Squad plays Yura the orgo
core receptionist Pete Davidson who also
appeared in The Suicide Squad as
blackguard is also listed in the credits
finally the villainous High evolutionary
is portrayed by chukudi iwuji who worked
with gun on the TV series Peacemaker
Peter Quill isn't known for his humility
he doesn't readily admit to having
weaknesses or making mistakes he is more
apt to try to talk his way out of an
argument or improvise his way out of a
problem then follow orders or ask for
help and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
he demonstrates these qualities yet
again several times over he insists on
taking rocket to the high evolutionary
even though Gamora repeatedly warns him
that it's a trap and as nebula points
out he and Groot nearly jumped to their
deaths trying to extract the secret code
from an orgo core crony's head when they
don't have a better idea Quill's
impulsivity most notably got him and
many others into serious trouble when he
interfered with the Avengers plan to
stop Thanos from using The Infinity
Gauntlet as it Dawns on him that Thanos
sacrificed Gamora he loses his cool and
begins putting a beat down on the Mad
Titan this breaks mantis's concentration
and before the rest of the gang can
remove the gauntlet Thanos is able to
complete his mission and snap half of
life out of existence but in an
orgoscope elevator quill shows major
growth admitting his Stakes I lost my
temper nearly destroyed half the
universe
fire speech is a hilarious summary of
the other
project events of
war and
well he left out some important
information that is
sometimes small details mean big things
for the plot the characters or the
themes of a movie other times they're
just a fun bit of World building and
that's the case with the Guardians of
the Galaxy movies and food what sets
this franchise within a franchise apart
from many other MCU properties is the
extent to which its world is thought out
characters have likes and dislikes
strengths and weaknesses and we know
them as well as their fellow characters
do quill is partial to tight-fitting
graphic t-shirts Gamora traditionally
fights with a sword but comes to
appreciate star-lord's blasters Groot
went through an angsty teenage phase in
which he struggled to lift his head from
his video games and Drax really likes
zargnuts zargnuts are the Guardians
equivalent of pre-packaged airplane
peanuts and the holiday special Drax
thinks mantis's secret is that she ate a
whole bowl of zargnats get over the song
and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 mantis
again asks for a zargnat and Drax tells
her they're all gone then he reaches
back into the bag and treats himself to
another another food-related Easter egg
during the battle on the orgoscope a
female humanoid can be seen eating a
yarrow root that she's clearly enjoying
it must mean it's ripe this is the very
same Galactic fruit that nebula hungers
for in volume 2 when she breaks out of
her restraints subdues the ravagers and
rocket and takes a bite she spits it out
in disgust the Guardians had warned her
that it wasn't ready to eat
jokes about metaphors run throughout the
trilogy and volume 1 when Quail calls
draxe walking thesaurus during the
team's Prison Break the green brawler
threatens Star-Lord quill defends
himself by explaining that it was just a
metaphor which Drax does not understand
nothing goes over my head my reflexes
are too fast I would catch it and volume
2 when asked about the meaning behind
his name taserface replies with a
familiar explanation it's metaphorical
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 takes the
literal use of metaphors to a whole new
level mantis implores Drax to give quill
a pep talk but he goes off script and
ends up poorly explaining the difference
between metaphors and analogies instead
the running metaphor joke also becomes
an opportunity to call back to one of
drax's other memorable comedic moments
in volume 2 rocket threatens to put
excrement in Quill's pillowcase and
clarifies it'll be one of drax's because
his droppings are huge at the end of his
metaphor analogy monologue Drax proudly
tells Peter that even his bodily
functions are figurative one time his
fecal matter looked like a fish
Peter Jason quill was born in 1980 in
Missouri and was whisked into space by
yandu in 1988. that means all of
star-lord's cultural references come
from that eight-year period the
character now in his 40s has physical
evidence for some of the Hallmarks of
his childhood he had his backpack with
him that fateful day which Gamora not
having any memories of Peter goes
through while she's left alone on his
ship besides the Polaroid of his family
it contains some elf stickers and
trading cards the exterior of the book
bag is decorated with patches of Pac-Man
ghosts in volume 2 Peter turns himself
into a giant Cosmic Pac-Man in his final
showdown against ego and some of those
elf stickers are plastered across the
control panel of his ship many of
Quill's verbal references hearken back
to the 80s as well he calls the high
evolutionary a Skeletor wannabe there's
also an allusion to another iconic movie
franchise that a young quill would have
been exposed to at one point Drax says I
have a bad feeling about this which is
an Easter egg of a line that gets
uttered again and again in Star Wars
movies
uh
for the most part the 31 films and nine
television series that make up the MCU
have been fairly family friendly they've
all carried a PG-13 rating often to tip
off parents about action movie style
violence mild swearing and pretty tame
adult situations Guardians of the Galaxy
was already Marvel's sauciest
sub-franchise as the movies contain far
more sexual innuendos more casual
cursing and some of the mcu's more
disturbing depths but Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 pushes the boundaries of
its PG-13 rating like never before
though it's also one of the funniest and
most heartfelt it's undoubtedly the
goriest and most obscene installment in
the MCU to date Adam Warlock Burns a
ravager down to his skeleton and the
high evolutionaries mask of his actual
face is removed revealing the pulpy
bloody skull that was left behind after
Rocket's attack there are sex jokes
aplenty including Quill's attempt to woo
Yura and Star-Lord has the honor of
letting slip the mcu's first ever F-bomb
now what open the door it's been a long
time coming and if it was ever going to
happen it's fitting that it happened in
a Guardians movie until now the
franchise has creatively worked around
the f word cutting away or having Groot
use it he says welcome to the freaking
Guardians of the Galaxy
only he didn't use freaking
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 opens with
an epic comedic fight sequence set to
the song Mr Blue Sky in which the
Guardians take on an agitated Obelisk
they're having a tough time taking the
massive toothy tentacled creature down
Drax convinces himself that the Obelisk
can only be killed from the inside out
since its height is too thick Gamora and
Star-Lord realize this doesn't make
sense and work together to get the Beast
to look up exposing a wound under its
chin Gamora switches from blasters to
blades and slices the Obelisk
practically in half at which point Drax
emerges from its innards believing
himself to have slain it single-handedly
in volume 3 nebula Drax and mantis are
captured by those loyal to the high
evolutionary and put in a dungeon of
sorts where it's assumed three angry
obelisks will make short work of them
it's a callback to that old fight scaled
up by three but one key detail has
changed at the beginning of volume 2 the
Guardians didn't have mantis on their
side rather than kill the obelisks
Mantis lays hands on them and assures
the team they won't be eaten she brings
the monsters under the guardian's
control and rescues them from their
captivity when mantis goes off to find
herself she does so with a trio of
obelisks in tow
like the Marvel villains turned Heroes
that have come before her nebula has
become a more likable and nuanced
character but she hasn't lost what we
loved about her as a baddie she's Moody
snarky and has a short fuse when it
comes to putting up with idiots yet
underneath her mostly cybernetic
exterior she's emotionally tough
thoughtful and eager to be of service
over the years nebula has formed a
special bond with rocket which becomes
evident when she gives him something
he'd long coveted in the Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special rocket opens
a large Oblong Box to find Bucky's
vibranium arm he'd previously offered to
buy the arm from the Winter Soldier when
they fought alongside each other in
Avengers Infinity war after Bucky
ignored him rocket remained undeterred
okay how much for the arms
oh I'll get that off
and he did after nebula came through as
a thank you rocket innovated a new arm
for nebula who is prone to losing limbs
in both the comics and the MCU this new
arm is a weapon and a tool with
seemingly infinite applications we know
that genius tinkerer rocket is
responsible for her upgrades because she
gives him credit before she uses it to
hack into the controls of the high
evolutionaries crashing ship
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is chock
full of religious undertones and imagery
that aren't just Easter eggs they're
intrinsic to the movie's central theme
about the Dignity of all life it's been
previously established that Peter
Quill's dad ego was an evil God and the
third film features Adam warlock's
virgin birth there's also talk of heaven
and a scene that involves a dying rocket
stealing a few moments with Lila in a
strange limbo space the final act in
which the Guardians use nowhere to
rescue humanoids and animals alike from
the high evolutionary ship is a clear
parallel to Noah's Ark and on the topic
of the high evolutionary when his
intelligent designs disappoint he washes
away his creations and his worlds in a
sea of flames not unlike Noah's flood he
claims that there are no Gods which is
why he had to step in to control
existence at least in the MCU we know
this isn't strictly true as we've seen
in the Thor films and eternals those
Gods might be ambivalent and highly
imperfect themselves but they are out
there the most overt reference comes
near the end when Adam Warlock uses an
outstretched finger to revive a lifeless
Peter Quill the Tableau is an
unmistakable Recreation of god-giving
Adam life from Michelangelo's Sistine
Chapel Fresco though in this instance
the roles are reversed
we have discussed how what makes the
Guardians weird is what makes them great
one of the weirdest things about this
franchise is Groot the sentient tree who
might be a little self-obsessed
[Music]
it might seem like he's only on the team
for comic relief but there's actually a
much deeper meaning hidden behind the
character and his three favorite words
in the first film there's a scene in
which Peter Quill frustrated that Groot
only ever says the same three words
follows him and Gamora through a
passageway and Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 there's a mirror of that scene
this time ravager Gamora follows Quail
through a hallway frustrated that she
can't understand the giant tree man but
by the end of the movie Gamora has
warmed to Groot and one of many moments
throughout the film's unexpectedly happy
resolution Groot nonchalantly says I
love you guys this moment might have
come as a shock to viewers but none of
the Guardians react in the slightest
that's because it symbolizes two things
first it's representative of the fact
that they all including ravager Gamora
understand Groot now second it's meant
to include the audience in their circle
of friends we can speak Groot now too
James Gunn has indicated that he
intended the first Guardians film to be
an exploration of mother figures in our
lives the second film is obviously about
the influence of Father figures while
the third film is a parable about
self-acceptance as part of Peter Quill's
Journey towards self-actualization he
realizes he must make peace with his
past and that means reconciling with his
grandfather Peter and his Grandpa didn't
have the warmest fuzziest relationship
so this isn't exactly something
star-lord's looking forward to when he
arrives at his childhood home where it
turns out that his mother's father is
still alive we learn that his name is
Jason that's also Peter's middle name
something we became aware of back in
volume 1 when star-lord's holographic
rap sheet revealed his full name to be
Peter Jason quill the mcu's take on the
character diverges from the comics but
his middle name is the same even if the
story behind it isn't star-lord's mother
in the comics was still Meredith quill
but his father was Jason a spartax
Emperor the powerful figure impregnated
Meredith and left her to fight an
Interstellar War Meredith is killed not
by a tumor but by aliens hostile to
Jason who want to end his bloodline
Marvel movies often use post-credits
scenes to introduce new characters one
of the only things about Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 that feels like a
traditional MCU entry is that it relies
on this convention in the first
post-credits scene we get a glimpse of
who will serve as the Guardians of the
Galaxy going forward rocket has been
promoted to team leader there's also
Kaiju Groot craglin Cosmo Adam Warlock
and a young blonde girl whom the rest
refer to as phyla we can assume that
this is the mcu's phylavel in the comics
she's Marvel's daughter and becomes a
Captain Marvel in her own Universe in
volume 3 the character is slightly
introduced when she's seen running
circles on a humanoid-sized hamster
wheel under the watchful eye of the high
evolutionary with the Marvel's due out
later this year there's a chance she
could reappear in the MCU sooner rather
than later if she's to remain a guardian
however her future is murkier with guns
departure there are no new Guardians
projects in development
in the original Guardians of the Galaxy
Peter Quill tells Tales of Earth's
Heroes including the Great Hero Kevin
Bacon fast forward to the Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special and mantis
and tracks wanting to get their friend
the best present ever decide to fly to
Earth and kidnap Quill's personal hero
bacon is understandably confused and
Afraid mantis uses her influence over
his emotions to calm him but when quill
realizes what they've done he makes her
break the spell at first bacon is
completely panicked to find himself in
space but after he and craglin have a
heart-to-heart the actor in the
Guardians Part as friends or so we
thought in the second post-credit scene
of Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 in
which Peter Quill and his grandfather
Jason are having breakfast Jason is seen
reading a newspaper the article on the
left of the front page explains that
Kevin Bacon claims to have been abducted
by aliens on the right side of the front
page is an article about a pug winning a
dog show it's less obvious than the
bacon Easter egg but it could refer to
blurp who has become Adam warlock's Pat
after killing its previous owner